I say to the cup of tea
that it is made of mud,
I use it once, if you drink it [
praise]
that you will get it equal to mud in mud,
then the music of mud will come again, come
show more, in the
meantime, some pic.  Stars Paaye
Channels O Jhal Ki
[Music]
Tea Lotus Tea is very important in India
and has been going on for a long time,
my Anand Shankar Pandit, I am working with clay,
this is what my father learned,
okay sir  These people have been following this tradition since long,
father used to make clay balls, we are
also making them and my son is also doing it, he is
following the tradition from 102 years ago, it has
happened
that this soil diamond becomes diamond in every rain.  The
name of many places is Ganga ji.
When the water level of Ganga ji decreases then they
cut the soil from there and fill it in the veins and
then after loading from there they bring it here.
Yes, one has to walk to Martis before hand.
That after making it sit on the wheel, we turn it into non-white
[music] It has
happened
that the roots are dried in the sun and we
burn them in our hands, after burning they turn
red in color, then
we have to hydrate them in the school and
take them to that shop.  I am
enjoying, it is time to make at
least four 508
[music] in Kalighat for
Ajay
that if plastic and steel are used then the
use of earthen utensils will have to be reduced and the
second thing which will decide on that is
clay.  It is not just in the soil, it
is Indian eco-friendly tea, which
you will find yourself in the necklace, you will not find it
in this team, you will find plastic,
it is very important to protect this art, so it does
not have to end,
I am running it.  Hai Parampara Chalega Aa
[Music]
Ajay Ko